bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat hier soir
très tard dans la soirée le sénat a
finalement adopté en seconde lecture
après de très nombreuses discussions le
projet de loi défendue par manuel valls
le ministre de l'intérieur sur les
scrutins électoraux mais sans sa mesure
phare le scrutin binominal paritaire qui
devait permettre d'élire un binôme
hommes femmes par canton lors des
prochaines élections cantonales en 2015
seuls les socialistes et les radicaux de
gauche ont soutenu le texte
il reste désormais aux députés et aux
sénateurs de s'entendre en commission
mixte paritaire sur une version commune
du texte avant que les députés ne
réexamine en seconde lecture dans les
prochains jours le texte
du coup le sénat veut peser de tout son
poids sur le texte final
lors de ces négociations car le texte
aborde d'autres aspects électoraux comme
par exemple le seuil à partir duquel le
scrutin proportionnel de liste devra
entrer en vigueur lors des prochaines
élections municipales
mais sans plus tarder direction
l'hémicycle pour revoir l'adoption de ce
texte très bonne journée à tous sur
public sénat mais ni monsieur y est
l'article 23 était important et c'est
vrai que la commission a apporté des
améliorations
je suis je pense que notamment la
rédaction proposée pour le de l'alinéa
13 par le gouvernement et mieux c'est
peut-être pas peine de rajouter un
d'écran concédé tape avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour cette haute
institution parce qu ils ont fini par en
mettre partout parce que plus en plus
c'est le le le chien qui se mord la
queue main un petit peu dans cette
affaire bon et ça fait mal ça fait très
mal
alors monsieur mehdi nous avions tout le
monde vous avez dit sur tous les bancs
qu'il fallait élargir la possibilité
quand on fait des quand on fait des
comparaisons avec des décisions du
conseil d'état du conseil
constitutionnel il faut quand même pas
oublier qu'on ne pouvait créer un canton
si un canton représentaient plus du
double de la super de la moyenne
départementale
oui mais enfin c'est est ce que suivait
le conseil d'état ivy d'accepter dans
ces cas là non le vrai problème c'est
qu'il y a des départements qui sont
extrêmement différents et que vous avez
quelques fois d'ailleurs on a entendu ça
une métropole
et puis un désert rue raffin désert une
très faible population rurale
c'est ça la question mais ça peut
exister aussi dans les départements qui
sont en pleine évolution qui ont une
partie très urbaine et une partie très
rurale et on n'a pas tenu compte des
évolutions qui a des départements qui
ont un million 250 mille habitants un
million trois cent cinquante mille
habitants qui ont 43 conseillers
généraux on voit des départements 200000
habitante qui en ont 45
c'est pas du tout pareil quand on parle
des réalités des conseils généraux on
vit pas de la même manière si on un
canton de 50000 habitants ou un canton
de dix mille parce que pour ça oui pour
certains départements ça ne posera pas
de problème
franchement on devrait pouvoir arriver
avec 20% et a fortiori 30% et avec les
aa résoudre le problème il y aura pas
vraiment de problème non monsieur le
ministre
comme on le fait pour la représente bien
sûr c'est pas du tout pareil
mais quand même c'est difficile il y
avait des amendements ils ont été
frappés l'article 40
mais quand même établir mieux une
certaine homogénéité entre les tous les
conseillers généraux de france pour
qu'il y en ait pas qui ont des 10 qui
auront 10 norme quand on est tous les
problèmes que ça pose parce que c'est
pas du tout pareil d'avoir 60 mille
habitants un grand territoire
et puis d'avoir dix mille habitants
parce que ça sera assez comparable à ce
que certains vivent aujourd'hui et je
crois que c'est la question mais ça on
n'a pas pu la résoudre parce qu'il
aurait fallu dire côté maintenant il y
aura un nombre de conseillers généraux
comme de conseillers municipaux en
fonction de la population un département
qui a tant de populations il aura tant
de conseillers généraux mais on n'a pas
pu aller jusque là et c'est quand même
la réelle difficulté il faut bien
rires mais néanmoins bien sûr nous
approuvons toutes les modifications qui
ont été apportées à l'article 23
on aurait préféré aussi quelques
aménagements supplémentaires
mais quand même c'est déjà pas mal merci
monsieur y est je vais donc mettre aux
voix l'article 23
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
de l'article 23 avis contraire je n'en
vois pas si monsieur ses vins l'article
23 est donc adoptée après l'article 23
amendements 97 rectifier c'est monsieur
laménie qui le défend immersive sur le
président seul ministre chers collègues
donc concernant cette cet amendement il
ya pour but dans le cadre du remodelage
la carte cantonale sur les conséquences
et la répartition au niveau de la
dotation de solidarité rurale au niveau
des nouveaux critères d'éligibilité
d'éligibilité donc il est en relation
directe donc avec l'article 23
si monsieur laménie avis de la
commission sur à porter ça vaut râble
défavorable pardon à vis du gouvernement
monsieur ministre retrait parce que
demande de retrait parce qu'il est de
fait satisfait merci monsieur laménie il
est retiré
je vous remercie article 24 demandes de
parole de monsieur antiste vous avez la
parole
monsieur le président monsieur
l'initiale collègues le 24 janvier 2010
les martiniquais se sont prononcés par
référendum en faveur de la création
d'une collectivité unique
la loi du 27 juillet 2011 adoptée suite
à cette consultation a permis la
constitution d'une commission tripartite
composée de représentants de la
préfecture de la région et du
département en charge de la bonne
conduite des travaux de fusil
entre la région et le département
initialement cette loi prévoyait
l'alignement des collectivité unique de
martinique et de guyane sur le
calendrier des élections régionales à
savoir en 2014 cependant la complexité
de la fusion des deux administrations et
de leur personnel s'est révélée plutôt
difficile plus difficile qu'on ne
pouvait l'imaginer nécessitant des
études plus pointus c'est d'ailleurs à
cela et à la mutualisation des services
que travaillent les deux exécutifs dans
le cadre de la commission ad-hoc qui
réunit des élus de la région et des élus
du département
au vu de la lourdeur objectif de cette
opération sensible et l'avancement des
travaux préparatoires relative à
l'installation de la collectivité unique
de martinique il n'est raisonnablement
pas possible de tenir l'échéance de 2014
en conséquence nous ne pouvons pas vu
l'importance de ce grand projet
politique de développement pour la
martinique prendre le risque d'un échec
les martiniquais ne nous le pardonnerait
pas et ils auraient raison
c'est pourquoi il n'est pas plus mal
pour moi que dans le cadre de la réforme
territoriale décidée par le président de
la république la mise en place de la
collectivité de martinique soit aligné
sur la modification des agendas
électoraux retenus au niveau national
soit en 2015
en effet ce temps supplémentaire
permettrait à la commission ad-hoc de
travailler dans des conditions plus
sereines à la refonte de tous les
services aussi bien administratif que
technique de la région et du département
pour rappel la fusion concerne non
seulement les patrimoines bâtis et
routier très conséquents mais aussi des
moyens financiers à hauteur d'un
milliard d'euros ainsi que la
finalisation des grands projets
opérationnels gestion des cem du galion
abattoirs départementale
équipements sportifs lycées et collèges
transport collectif en site propre et
les projets de fond système informatique
organisations financières et comptables
notamment
je souligne aussi que la commission et
nous quelques élus martiniquais
travaillons en étroite collaboration
avec les syndicats des personnels très
attentifs au devenir des agents plutôt
inquiet
deux mille deux cents agents pour le
département et 1200 pour la région
j'avoue ne pas comprendre les cris
d'orfraie concernant le report des
élections de martinique en 2015 au lieu
de 2014
j'analyse ces manifestations
d'opposition comme étant des manoeuvres
politiciennes au bénéfice d'intérêts
électoralistes en effet ceux qui veulent
aller vite ne parce qu'au succès
personnel de lure listes ont fait le
pont et puis la rivière viendra après
faire élections de suite et après on
organise malheureusement leur
préoccupation n'est pas fondée sur
l'intérêt général de la martinique et le
respect du choix des martiniquais d'une
collectivité de droit commun mais juste
sur une volonté de revanche la
différence que je défends et pragmatique
elle correspond davantage aux attentes
de l'électeur qui portent plus sur le
fond que sur une date et une forme on
pourrait me rétorquer alors en pourquoi
pas dans dix ans mais je répondrai
qu'est-ce que quelques mois de plus
quand on veut se donner toutes les
chances de réussir cette fusion
ainsi la seule exigence d'un calendrier
différencier n'a à mon sens aucun
intérêt ne soyons pas frileux avec des
arguties politique mais attachons nous à
prendre le temps d'une réussite
ce que d'ailleurs le peuple martiniquais
attend de nous
oui donc à 2015 conformément aux
délibérations des deux assemblées
martiniquaise des 22 novembre 2012
pour le conseil régional et le 13
décembre 2012 pour le conseil général
ainsi que celle des deux assemblées
guyanaise à une très forte majorité
j'espère que mes arguments auront
découragé les auteurs des amendements
qui viennent et il me plaît de citer ici
un grand homme de chez nous le docteur
pierre aliker premier adjoint d'aimé
césaire pendant 45 ans âgé aujourd'hui
de 106 ans qui disait les meilleurs
spécialistes des affaires martiniquaises
sont les martiniquais eux mêmes mais
c'est mon cher collègue deux amendements
faisant l'objet d'une mission commune le
41 rectifié de monsieur y est oui
monsieur le président les amendements
ils sont liés au fait que nous ne
souhaitons pas qu'on reporte des
élections régionales dans tous les
amendements qui ont été déposés seront
dans ce sens donc je défends tous les
amendements que j'ai déposée sur cet
article
dit monsieur s faire gagner du temps le
145 il a défendu monsieur marseille et
l'a défendu à vis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur défavorable
monsieur le président à vie du
gouvernement défavorable je les mets
donc on voit quels sont ceux qui sont
pour l'adoption de ces deux amendements
avis contraire ils ne sont pas adopté
deux amendements aussi faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le 144 de ces
monsieurs marseille qui le défend il
défendu monsieur y est vous l'avez
défendu aussi le vôtre le 56 avis des
commissions
même avis du gouvernement oui même vote
que les précédents ils sont rejetés
je mets donc on voit l'article 24 quels
sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption de
l'article 24
un lit contraire il est adopté l'article
25 un amendement de monsieur y est le 43
rectifier il a été défendu même voix
même avis de la commission même avis du
gouvernement même vote
il est rejeté le chat 46 de monsieur
kétou c'est le même vote
il est rejeté et je mets donc on voit
l'article 25 quels sont ceux qui sont
pour l'adoption de l'article 25 avis
contraire il est adopté même voiture le
25 bis même vote 25 terre idem
nous en arrivons l'article 26 et
l'amendement 271 rectifié qu'il défend
madame prima il a défendu avis de la
commission sur les 271 rectifié monsieur
le rapporteur
mais je vous en prie l'avis de la
commission sur 271 rectifié défavorable
même avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre c'est lequel
oui mais une minute puisque j'avais déjà
eu l'occasion de m'exprimer nous sommes
sur celui sur les 271 1 présentée par
monsieur de witt montgolfier qui permet
de ramener le seuil de 10% des inscrits
à 12,5 pour cent puisque c'est cet
élément là donc nous donnons un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
conformément à l'engagement que j'avais
pris devant votre assemblée
oui madame la sénatrice et mieux que les
deux premiers oui voilà monsieur mercier
c'est bien il vous je vais donc on voit
l'amendement des 171 rectifié qui a reçu
l'avis favorable du gouvernement quels
sont ceux qui sont pour l'adopter avis
contraire il est adopté et l'article 26
est donc supprimée alors après l'article
26 l'amendement 140 c'est monsieur boyer
qu'il défend oui hein donc comme nous le
savons le sous-préfet en zone de
montagne en zrr jouent un rôle
déterminant en service de l'aménagement
du territoire et de son organisation
sont même tient notamment au coeur des
espaces difficile des zones de montagne
est un enjeu pour l'avenir notre
territoire afin d'assurer je dirais une
forme d'égalité et d'éviter ainsi une
rupture administrative dévastatrice avec
l'apparition de nouveaux cantons il
assurera un lien de l'administration
décentralisée de notre pays
il sera le dernier rempart contre la
désertification administrative qui
risque de se produire si l'on maintienne
plus sinon mais si l'on ne maintient
plus l'essence même des services publics
et des services aux puits
en milieu rural et angers derrère vis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur de
gouvernement défavorable aux ses
explications de vote monsieur le noir en
réalité le président je voudrais avoir
une explication une réponse de la part
du ministre sur un point très précis
nous avons des zones de revitalisation
rurale actuellement qui sont dans des
cantons les cantons qui vont être
supprimés dans peu de temps
alors quel est le sort qui est réservé
aux territoires
aujourd'hui quand on bénéficiant du
régime de la zrr dès lors que ce
territoire est englobée dans un
territoire plus importants qui ne sera
pas évidemment dans sa globalité
classé en zrr c'est important d'un point
de vue notamment fiscales pour des
entreprises
deux ministres je veux bien évidemment
répondre même si on est quand même sur h
c'est un sujet qui est totalement
indépendant effectivement monsieur y est
c'est à dire que les politiques de
revitalisation ou concernent des
communes concernent des communautés de
communes concerne des citoyens donc de
toutes façons ces territoires
ils sont pas uniquement en fonction des
cantons si en fonction de cette
situation donc ils seront maintenus
après il peut y avoir des adaptations à
la marge
évidemment l'état suivra ces évolutions
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement 140 qui a reçu d'avis
défavorables et de la commission du
gouvernement quels sont ceux qui sont
pour l'adopter avis contraire il n'est
pas adopté je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi
est ce qu'il y a des demandes
d'explications de vote madame kuperman
puisque résidant à monsieur nice mes
chers collègues excusez moi mais
peut-être une pointe d'ironie en cette
heure tardive puisque je vais vous
demander beaucoup d'efforts et
d'imagination
plus que le binôme la réunion une même
personne ce que je m'exprime au nom de
mon collègue paul vergès
donc je vous demande de l'indulgence et
j'ouvre les guillemets ces deux projets
de loi préfigure ce que sera ou ce que
pourrait être l'acte iii de la
décentralisation
si la volonté du gouvernement est de ne
pas toucher à l'architecturé actuelle
pour la france hexagonale
il convient de rappeler qu'à la réunion
la situation est tout à fait différente
sur tous les plans géographique
économique social politique et bien sûr
institutionnels
la loi du 19 mars 1946 montre
aujourd'hui de toute évidence qu'elle
n'est plus à même de répondre aux défis
nouveaux du développement elle a épuisé
ses possibilités la martinique
notre collègue le rappelait et la guyane
ont opté pour une collectivité unique
la guadeloupe pour l'instant et la
réunion reste ul dans le droit commun et
voix sur leur même territoire
fonctionner un conseil général et un
conseil régional et pour notre part nous
n'avons jamais caché qu'il nous fallait
procéder à une rupture historique depuis
quelques mois à la réunion la presse
fait l'écho de commentaires qui
convergent vers la même analyse le statu
quo institutionnel n'est plus possible
et il faut ouvrir une nouvelle page
après celle initiée par la loi de 46 les
textes que nous étudions aujourd'hui ne
prennent pas en compte notre réalité
géographique et nous pensons la
possibilité d'intégration dans notre
environnement géographique immédiat
notre réalité économique et notre
réalité institutionnelle comme nous
l'avions souligné lors de la première
lecture contrairement à la guadeloupe
qui peut mobiliser un congrès la réunion
par les dispositions spécifiques et
particulières se trouve interdite du
droit de faire connaître son opinion
pour cela il faudrait parvenir à une
réforme institutionnelle et il
appartient au gouvernement de prendre
l'initiative aboutissant à la
consultation de la population
réunionnaise sur les modalités et les
objectifs d'une réforme institutionnelle
adapté à la situation de la réunion
dès lors il est bien évident que ces
deux textes que nous étudions ne sont
pas adaptés à la situation spécifique de
la réunion tout cela explique notre
position sur ce projet de loi comme dans
la première lecture donc paul vergès n'a
pris part à aucun les voitures les
amendements elle ne prendra pas part au
vote sur le vote final de ces deux
textes jour merci merci madame monsieur
y est
oui monsieur le président bien
évidemment le sujet qui nous divise est
avec le gouvernement ces minots c'était
le sujet essentiel
sans doute sera-t-il voter puisque ya
une majorité à l'assemblée pour le voter
et pour avoir le dernier mot mais nous
avons marqué notre position et pas
seulement nous puisque le sénat a
confirmé son vote de première lecture
sur ce point
néanmoins il y avait déjà tout le volet
intercommunalité fléchage et cetera où
je crois que à la fois le seuil on ait
on a trouvé un consensus sur le seuil je
pense que c'était important et qui
correspond bien sûr ils trouveront des
communes qui te diront c'est moi ou mes
cetab un bon consensus je crois
et à mon équilibre et deuxièmement aussi
et grâce notamment à l'arrêt chara au
rapporteur etc c'est que nous avons
assoupli aussi les conditions
désignation des délégués intercommunaux
et je pense que c'est aussi une avancée
alors que le l'assemblée nationale
n'avait gardé le système sans regarder
exactement mais on n'avait pas texter
vrai du sénat sur cette question
deuxièmement il est évident aussi que en
ce qui concerne le la délimitation des
cantons pour l'instant pour l'instant
qui reste le nombre actuel mais il a
évoluera peut-être je crois que avoir
élargi à 30% la possibilité de variation
entre la population des cantons
tout en respectant je crois quand même
la fille l'esprit des décisions du
conseil d'état et du conseil
constitutionnel parce que monsieur
richard vous n'avez pas cité une
décision c'est la décision sur la
réforme du sénat où on peut aussi
représenter les territoires et pas
seulement la démographie et oui rappelez
vous quand même cette décision qui est
extrêmement importante puisqu'elle
limite aussi les possibilités de
tripatouiller la représentation au sénat
je le rappelle quand même donc pour
toutes ces raisons et monsieur le
ministre vous avez 1 ap en faisant donne
un avis favorable à l'amendement de nos
collègues de l'autre craze bong golfier
à l'article 26 bien entendu c'est
uniquement pour l'instant ça ne
s'appliquerait pas la disparition 10%
tout de suite mais on a bien compris
aussi que si nous n'avons pu l'examiner
puisque c'étaient des articles de
conséquences
vous l'aviez dit que vous était tout à
fait prêt à une ouverture sociale est
vous l'avez prouvé déjà dans ce dans ce
cas c'est pourquoi compte tenu de ces
choses nous ne sommes pas satisfaits de
ce qui se fait pour paris nous disons et
nous leur disons donc à partir de ce
moment là monsieur le ministre il parce
qu'il faut un texte pour senna ce que je
crois que c'est important surtout en
deuxième lecture en première lecture on
peut dire on vote rien mais en deuxième
lecture une part est un poste important
qui est un texte comme ils nous
satisfait pas complètement mais il ya
beaucoup d'avancées positives
le groupe ump s'abstiendra merci
monsieur y est ce monsieur kalt mback
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nos débats
sur ce projet de loi auront été une
nouvelle fois particulièrement riche
alors ils n'ont pas duré 32 heures comme
en première lecture mais je crois que
nous avons largement débattu de tous les
points de ce projet de loi le sénat a
encore su démontrer la fine connaissance
des territoires qui est la sienne et je
me félicite que nos débats et était
beaucoup plus apaisé qu'en première
lecture notamment sur la question de la
parité
je veux ici remercier la qualité du
précieux travail fourni par le
rapporteur michel delbarre je veux
également salué l'attachement du
président de la commission des lois jean
pierre sueur en commission puis tout au
long de l'examen de ce texte en séance
publique pour favoriser le dialogue et
le rassemblement du sénat sur des points
forts comme toujours
chers collègues je veux enfin attirer
votre attention sur la volonté qui a été
celle du ministre de l'intérieur
manuel valls et du gouvernement de
prendre en compte nos travaux durant la
seconde lecture de ce projet de loi
monsieur le ministre vous avez su très
souvent entendre les revendications du
sénat qui s'emploie à relever à relayer
les attentes des élus locaux et vous
avez eu à coeur d'associer en faisant un
nombre certain de concessions sur le
contenu du texte la chambre haute à la
définition du futur proche de loi vous
avez ainsi démontré là encore une fois
votre grand sens de l'écouté du
compromis
je crois que vous avez su faire preuve
d'un profond respect du rôle du sénat et
je tenais à vous en remercier
je pense qu'il est essentiel maintenant
que ce texte soit adopté et je veux dire
que je suis rassurée par l'intervention
de monsieur y est qui en annonçant
l'abstention du groupe ump lève le
suspense sur le vote final
je crois qu'il était essentiel en effet
que nous soyons présents dans la suite
du débat en ayant un texte voté par le
sénat le texte donc sera votée
malheureusement l'article 2 sur le
scrutin binominal ne sera pas lui
dans le texte voté par le sénat et je
regrette que notre haute assemblée n'est
pas souhaité s'associer à la révolution
que constituera la parité dans les
conseils départementaux
je crois que grâce à ce scrutin
binominal nos conseils départementaux
vont connaître une véritable révolution
néanmoins notre haute assemblée a su
adopter de nouvelles propositions fortes
que nous aurons à coeur de défendre dans
la suite du débat parlementaire
je pense tout d'abord au tunnel au
tunnel a plus ou moins 30% pour le
redécoupage qui va donner beaucoup plus
de souplesse pour prendre en compte la
spécificité des territoires et notamment
des territoires ruraux
c'était une demande forte des locaux
et je crois que notre haute assemblée a
su se faire entendre du gouvernement
le deuxième point sur lequel nous avons
des avancées qu'il faut préserver
c'est le fléchage pour
l'intercommunalité
un fléchage qui ne sera pas limitée au
début de la liste qui pourrait être plus
large
je crois que là aussi c'était une
demande forte de tous ceux qui sont
amenés dans un an à constituer des
listes et à mener des campagnes
électorales
il ne voulait pas être contraint pour
les élus communautaires au début de la
liste
grâce à ce vote nous allons offrir des
marges de souplesse pour la constitution
des listes municipales avec ce fléchage
intercommunale troisième point le seuil
pour le scrutin proportionnel dans les
petites communes un consensus scrutin de
liste le un consensus s'est établi dans
cette assemblée autour du seuil de 1000
habitants
je crois que c'est un juste compromis
entre ceux qui voulaient 0 ou 5 cents
entre ceux qui voulaient 1500 avec un
seuil à 1000
nous avons là un point d'équilibré qu'il
nous faudra maintenir et puis enfin il y
avait ce vote par l'assemblée de la
réduction de deux élus dans les conseils
municipaux de moins de 3500 habitants
là encore le texte revient à la
situation intérieure et je crois que il
fallait rendre hommage à l'action de nos
élus municipaux parfaitement bénévoles
est souvent indispensable à la vie
locale
là encore le sénat a su démontrer qu'ils
ne savaient en temps l'inquiétude de
celles et ceux qui oeuvrent
quotidiennement dans nos territoires les
plus ruraux à faire vivre à l'action
publique
pour toutes ces raisons les quatre
principales et bien d'autres puisque le
débat a été riche et le texte a été
largement amendé
l'adoption de ce texte permettra de
moderniser la vie démocratique de
territoire nous sommes extrêmement
satisfaits au sein du groupe socialiste
qu'un texte sorte nos travaux en seconde
lecture
ici au sénat il convient maintenant de
continuer à le faire vivre mes chers
collègues le groupe socialiste vous
invite à adopter ce projet de loi ainsi
modifié soit en votant favorablement
soit si vous n'êtes pas encore
complètement convaincu en vous abstenant
en vous abstenant et je pense également
également aux élus centristes mais aussi
à nos partenaires en permettant ainsi
aux débats parlementaires de se
poursuivre et et je félicite à la
demande du président ménard le président
d'ab semaine qui a su suivre ce texte
avec attention et qui grâce à ses
interventions particulièrement
pertinente permet aujourd'hui l'adoption
de ce texte le rassemblement du sénat
pour continuer à ensemble défendre nos
territoires et les élus locaux
voilà le groupe socialiste votera donc
favorablement et le débat pourra
continuer je tenais à le souligner et à
remercier toutes celles et tous ceux qui
ont participé à ce débat sur les modes
de scrutin et le calendrier électoral
mercenaires c'est monsieur ne sert même
ceux présents chers collègues ce texte
est cette réforme n'est pas une réforme
consensuelle sur le binôme et ça nous le
savions avant même de commencer un aux
travaux jean tient lé taux n'est
cependant à dire que en dépit de ce
désaccord de fond la qualité du travail
en commission des lois la qualité du
climat en commission des lois a
participé très largement à
l'amélioration de ce texte
et cette qualité nous l'avons retrouvée
au niveau de l'hémicycle à la fois dans
le travail et dans le climat et je crois
que on peut en rendre hommage également
au ministre j'ajouterai que j'ai quand
même pris un petit coup de blues un
petit coup de déprime en entendant tout
à l'heure mon collègue le président
mézard invoquée
une sorte de crépuscule de l'institution
parlementaire et l'impuissance
effectivement du parlement alors je
partage pas totalement cette opinion
quoique je ne la partage pas totalement
puisque il me semble que la récente
révision constitutionnelle a plutôt
augmenté les pouvoirs du parlement que
ce soit sur les pouvoirs de la
commission où que ce soit sur la
suppression d'un certain nombre de
méthodes de rationalisation du
parlementarisme
il n'en reste pas moins que malgré tout
cela on nous en sommes aujourd'hui à
nous demander si le passage du tunnel de
20 à 30% ne pourrait pas encourir les
fourches caudines et la censure du
conseil constitutionnel
alors je me gavais quand même de
rappeler qu' il est inscrit dans la
constitution qu à la souveraineté
nationale appartient au peuple et que le
peuple exerce soit par ses représentants
sont par là près du référendum et que
donc si nous allions vers ce type de
gouvernement des juges
il resterait quand même une possibilité
au parlement et sur ce point vous savez
que senna a des pouvoirs équivalents à
ceux de l'assemblée nationale c'est de
faire préciser puisque bientôt après
tout nous aurons une réforme
constitutionnelle faire précisé dans le
texte de la constitution que la
représentation du territoire est
également un élément fondamental car mes
chers collègues
vous savez que même si ces chiffres sont
schématique on dit aujourd'hui qu'il y a
80% des personnes qui vivent en secteur
urbain sur 20% du territoire ce qui
signifie qu'il ya peut-être 20% des
personnes qui vivent en secteur rural
mais sur 80% du territoire et que c'est
ce type de pourcentage ne peut qu'aller
en progressant ce qui ce qui veut dire
au passage d'ailleurs que les
territoires ruraux deviennent
fondamentaux non seulement pour les
ruraux qui habite mais également pour
les citadins qui en ont besoin
pour l'heure des tentes leurs loisirs et
leurs oxygène si le conseil
constitutionnel ne le comprenais pas il
faudrait peut-être que le parlement
fasse en sorte comme en modifiant la
constitution il puisse bien longtemps
merci monsieur le cercle monsieur favier
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues donc nous
arrivons au terme de nos débats avec le
sentiment malgré l'heure tardive d'un
travail inachevé et même en partie
précipité en intervention général nous
parlions déjà d'un rendez vous manqué
cependant neutrons avec satisfaction que
nos débats furent je crois la hauteur
des enjeux tant dans le contenu des
diverses propositions portées par toutes
les sénatrices et sénateurs qui se sont
exprimés que dans l' écoute donc chacune
et chacun d'entre nous a fait preuve il
est d'autant plus dommageable que le
résultat dans nos débats n'est pas donc
déboucher sur des modifications plus
substantielle de ce texte
vous aviez pourtant monsieur le ministre
une majorité prête à soutenir des
propositions que vous auriez pu entendre
sans autre refus de bouger sur les
articles importants lui était possible
de parvenir à un accord
nous en sommes encore persuadé malgré
des conditions d'examen limité en termes
de temps et même ça a été rappelé par
certains à la limite de l'irrespect pour
notre haute assemblée nous avions dès le
début tenu à souligner et nombreux
points d'accord que nous avions et qui
demeure oui nous restons favorables au
changement non des conseils généraux à
la nécessité de revoir le mode de
scrutin et de modifier le périmètre des
cantons continuent évidemment de des
inégalités insupportables notamment au
plan démographique
oui nous vous soutenons dans votre
objectif de favoriser un pas décisif
vers la féminisation de nos assemblées
départementales mais d'autres solutions
existaient pour y parvenir sans recourir
à ce scrutin binominal qui ne tardera
pas dont on ne parlera pas avoir
évidemment les limites
oui nous vous soutenons pour reculer les
dates des futures élections
départementales et régionales pour
élargir aussi le nombre des communes qui
devront dorénavant éliront leur conseil
municipal au scrutin de liste
même si nous regrettons que beaucoup
d'entre elles
seront encore exclue de ce mode de
scrutin qui est pourtant sans conteste
au service du développement notre
démocratie locale et renforce à parité
dans les conseils municipaux
certes il est vrai le coeur de ce projet
de loi
savoir les articles 2 et 20 nécessitait
à nos yeux d'être fortement revues sur
le dernier concernant donc la
désignation des délégués communautaires
il suffisait simplement de reprendre le
choix majoritaire exprimé par les élus
locaux à qui nous avions donné la parole
à l'occasion des états généraux
organisés par notre sénart il y a
quelques mois
aussi notre proposition n'était pas
dogmatique mais raisonnable et
respectueuse d'un avis largement partagé
par les élus de divers horizons pour
l'article 2 sur le mode de scrutin
départemental
il est vrai que le chemin de l'accord
était plus difficile mais notre position
de repli aurait mérité d'être regardé de
plus près y compris à l'occasion d'un
dialogue en amont de l'écriture de ce
projet comme d'autres propositions
d'ailleurs que ce soit comme nous le
proposions une liste d'une liste
départementale corrigeant par la
proportionnelle les excès du scrutin
majoritaire s'appliquait rappelons le
ici sur la base d'un scrutin
territorialisée qui aurait d'ailleurs pu
être effectivement un scrutin binominal
bien encore comme d'autres en ont fait
la proposition de sectoriser les
départements pour introduire un scrutin
proportionnel au plus près des électeurs
pour répondre justement à ce que vous
avez beaucoup évoqué ce besoin de
proximité chacun le sait vous même
monsieur le ministre comme les sénateurs
socialistes d'ailleurs les solutions ne
manquaient pas pour permettre de trouver
une solution qui pouvait alors réunir
une majorité sénatoriale
malheureusement le chemin de la
concertation ne fut pas le vôtre assurer
que vous êtes effectivement d'avoir une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale et vous
fait malheureusement le choix du passage
en force à l'assemblée et nous le
regrettons l'importance numérique
l'hégémonie de votre groupe
parlementaire ou permet donc d'être
sourd aux propositions de vos
partenaires
mais ils pourront aussi parfois aveugle
en réalité qui vous entoure et aux
opinions qui s'expriment
nous le regrettons mais dans ces
conditions vous comprendrez que nous ne
pourrons pas évidemment voté en faveur
de ce texte
s'agissant de la dernière lecture pour
le sénat il nous faut donc évidemment
pour nous choisir pour ou contre ce
texte
une abstention d'ouverture au dialogue
n'étant plus aujourd'hui à cette
heure-là battant de mise
la perche qui était attendu n'ayant pas
été saisie nous ne pouvons donc que
voter effectivement malheureusement
contre ce projet en l'état en regrettant
finalement que les décisions qui nous
sont proposés n'ai pas trouvé place au
lendemain de l'examen du futur projet de
loi de décentralisation comme certains
l'ont d'ailleurs évoqué nous aurions pu
alors mettre en adéquation le mode
d'élection des élus départementaux avec
l'émission de la collectivité
territoriale qu'ils seront appelés à
gérer je pense qu'effectivement si nous
avions traité c'est que ces questions
dans cet ordre là sans doute que nous
aurions certainement pu trouver des
solutions plus satisfaisante pour les
les ces nouveaux modes de scrutins
départementaux
merci monsieur favier monsieur mercier
et merci beaucoup je vais pas du
ministre mes chers collègues
au terme de ce débat qui a été un débat
de bonne qualité qui se déroulait dans
une ambiance sereine où et qui a permis
je crois au sénat de dégager une
position
il y a à ce soir un texte et il est
important qu'ils aient un texte dans un
système bicaméral
il faut que les deux assemblées puissent
dialoguer et dialoguer dans l'enceinte
où elles seront sol c'est-à-dire la
commission mixte paritaire et c'est le
parlement qui exercera la plénitude de
son pouvoir au sein de cette commission
mixte paritaire
mais pour que cela fonctionne il faut
qu'il y ait un texte de chacune des
assemblées il peut être le même
il peut être différent il sera différent
et je crois que c'est bien assez
je voudrais d'abord féliciter et
remercier toutes celles et ceux qui ont
participé à l'élaboration de ce texte
commission des lois le rapporteur
président de gouvernement qui a fait des
efforts nécessaires et puis l'ensemble
des membres du sénat ceux de la majorité
un tout petit peu et ceux de
l'opposition
beaucoup bien entendu sinon il n'aurait
pas de sens mais il y a une position du
sénat et il faudra pelé il y a d'abord
le rejet du système binominal deux fois
de saidal a rejeté c'est ainsi c'est la
position du sénat ça peut faire plaisir
ou pas plaisir mais c'est la position du
sénat et il y à un accord assez large
sur toutes les questions relatives aux
élections des conseillers municipaux et
l'intercommunalité la recherche d'un
seuil pour l'application de la loi du
système électoral à la proportionnelle
majoritaire qui est maintenant
complètement entré dans nos moeurs est
une bonne chose
mille habitants je crois que c'est bien
mais on peut le dire clairement
fortement et cette position viendra en
cmp et non pas un peu par hasard cacher
mais comme une vraie position de
l'assemblée qui représente les
collectivités territoriales et c'est une
bonne chose
nous avons également su prendre certain
nombre de mesures sur l'intercommunalité
la désignation un peu plus lié au
suffrage universel des conseillers
communautaires même s'il faudra
probablement aller plus loin un jour le
respect de la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel et du conseil d'état
je crois qu'il faut pas regretter et
d'appliquer les décisions du conseil
constitutionnel
notre système on sent derrière ils
essaient souvent repose sur ce que
j'appelle un état de droit un état de
droit je rappelle que c'est pas un état
où le parlement fait ce qu'il veut c'est
pas possible c'est pas d'état de droit
ça l'état de droit on respecte les
règles constitutionnelles
qu'une juridiction est chargé de faire
appliquer et c'est assez récent dans
notre système mais c'est je crois un
progrès là aussi il y à d'autres bonnes
choses dans ce texte je veux pas revenir
sur tout ce qui a fait la queue mais je
voudrais insister entendez du centriste
sur le fait qu' on n'a pas décidé de
retenir pour se présenter au second tour
les deux candidats arrivés en tête
mais et tout ce qu'ils avaient à dire un
certain pourcentage nous est venue
pourtant c'est très bien ainsi
c'est aussi une avancée de la démocratie
quelque part pour toutes ces raisons
groupe centriste est satisfait qu'il y
ait un texte clair de la part du sénat
il y a des poids sur lequel nous sommes
en divergence mais nous ferons en sorte
que ce texte puisse exister en nous
abstenant merci monsieur merci monsieur
le président mézard merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues notre groupe votera
majoritairement le texte du sénat il
fallait un texte du sénat il y en a un
qui va être votée est telle qu'il est je
dois dire que il convient à la majorité
d'entre nous en effet l'article 2 n'a
pas assez été votée donc ce qui
satisfait une majorité de mes collègues
de mon groupe et sur les autres
dispositions grâce aux efforts aux
propositions qui ont été faites par les
uns par les autres et aussi aller coûte
que vous avez bien voulu avoir monsieur
le ministre il y a eu des évolutions
tout à fait positive
je pense au seuil de 1000 habitants ce
qui concerne les élections municipales
je pense au nombre de conseillers
municipaux qui reste stable et là on a
entendu ce que nous avions dit en
première lecture c'est qu'il était
nécessaire d'écouter nos collègues
conseillers municipaux et maires dans
nos territoires sur le fléchage aussi
je crois que les dispositions qui ont
été retenus vont dans le bon sens et
recueille une large majorité et nous
avons pris acte bien sûr que l'assemblée
nationale il y aurait le vote du binôme
du système du principe mais vous avez
bien voulu faire un effort monsieur le
ministre en nous indiquant que le
gouvernement serait d'accord pour
essayer de conserver cette disposition
sur les équilibres démographiques entre
-30 et +30 ce qui correspond à un
progrès évident quand on regarde la
situation de nombre de dents département
parce que nous savons pertinemment qu'en
restant aux dispositions moins 20 + 20
il n'y a pas que les zones de montagne
les zones dites air littoral suite été
encore pire avec la densification dans
les grandes villes du littoral
on veut penser que le reste du
territoire départemental aurait suffi à
remplir un seul ou deux cantons ce qui
est absolument inacceptable et contraire
à l'intérêt général
donc cette disposition est un progrès
cela n'évacue pas quand même le problème
du nombre du des cantons et moi je
regrette qu'on n'ait pas pu avoir de
véritable débat là dessus
puisqu'on nous avons posé ici l'article
40 ce qui me paraît pas une excellente
chose mais dont il faudra que nous en
prenions notre et que nous en prenons
acte est la suite de l'évolution du
texte devant l'assemblée nationale donc
le texte tel qu'il est votée par le
sénat nous paraît correspondre pour
l'essentiel à un progrès par rapport à
ce qu'il était auparavant et nous le
voterons majoritaire merci monsieur le
président je mets au voit donc
l'ensemble du projet de voie de le
projet de loi dans la commission a ainsi
rédigé l'intitulé projet de loi relatif
à l'élection des conseillers
départementaux des conseillers
municipaux des conseillers
communautaires
et modifiant le calendrier électoral
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
de ce texte avis contraire abstention le
projet de loi est adopté
monsieur le ministre oui très rapidement
monsieur le président avant que nous
abordions la loi en organique
d'abord je voulais remercier le sénat
non seulement pour ce vote mais surtout
sur pour la qualité du travail accompli
je pense très sérieusement que le rendez
vous auquel j'appelais au début de notre
discussion pour cette deuxième lecture
est en partie réussie et grâce à la
qualité de ses travaux
je remarque nous avons confirmé le
report des élections en 2015 qu'il y a
eu des changements profonds concernant
l'intercommunalité notamment pour aller
vers ce suffrage direct que nous
appelions touch me semble-t-il
en tout cas beaucoup de nos voeux le
seuil à 1000 qui a fait consensus
tout cas qui a recueilli une grande
majorité sinon l'avis de tous permettra
aussi à la parité de s'appliquer pour
plusieurs millions de nos concitoyens
nous avons confirmé vous avez confirmé
l'abrogation du conseiller territorial
le sénat a défini il ya encore un
instant des critères pour le redécoupage
pour permettre un bon équilibre
démographique et de nos territoires et
avec ce tunnel ce nouveau tunnel de plus
30 - 30 et enfin président mercier l'a
souligné nous avons aussi trouver une
majorité pour le seuil afin d'être
qualifiés au 2e tour à 12,5 pour cent de
ce point de vue là je vous ai remerciés
et la majorité et l'opposition
évidemment le président la commission
des lois et le rapporteur qui a été
comme d'habitude d'une aide tout à fait
précieuse et ainsi nous avons trouvé un
point d'équilibré
évidemment manque le binôme
c'était au coeur du débat
mais là les esprits ayant évolué je
l'ait remarqué à la fois aussi bien dans
le ton dans les armements utilisés ou
dans la volonté de discuter aussi
l'article de par le rejet des
amendements de suppression
je ne doute pas un seul instant que
l'assemblée complétera ce manque qu'un
accord une manière ou d'une autre a
trouvé à la fin de ces discussions
soient en cmp ce moment du texte final
je me porte garant en tout cas devant
vous pour que les avancées qui ont été
accomplis à l'occasion de ce débat
puisse être portée aussi par le
gouvernement devant l'assemblée
nationale et je reste convaincu comme je
les dis que ce texte à la fois sur
l'intercommunalité comme par
l'instauration du binôme qui sera
confirmée par l'assemblée nationale
changera durablement et dans le bon sens
l'organisation de nos territoires merci
monsieur le ministre nous passons donc
maintenant la discussion des articles du
projet de loi organique et l'article 1er
à avec un amendement 11 rectifier c'est
monsieur collomb bas monsieur mézard
qu'il défend monsieur colombes à cet
article premier a été pour nous une
surprise dans la mesure où ça nous a été
dit plusieurs fois pensons que
s'agissant des règles de cumul
il y avait d'un texte qui était en
préparation
tout à l'heure on nous a aussi alain
richard a aussi évoqué le fait que
peut-être il faudrait cesser de parler
du cumul des mandats mais parler
peut-être des fonctions donc
7 on a eu un peu l'impasse j'ai eu un
peu l'impression que on appliquer parce
qu'il y avait un texte quelque part
alors il fallait immédiatement faire les
correctifs qui s'imposent donc nous
pensons que c'est une sorte de cavaliers
qui n'a rien à faire ici et en plus ce
qui pose d'énormes problèmes et pose
d'autant plus de problèmes que si on n'a
pas encore réglé l'appareil a pas eu de
décision concernant le cumul en matière
de mandat parlementaire et on se met à
légiférer en matière de cumul des
communes des modes et des élus des
communes entre mille et trois mille cinq
cents habitants
c'est quand même un petit peu
extraordinaire en plus s'agissant de la
date d'entrée en vigueur de cet article
est ce que il entrera en vigueur tout de
suite ce qui semble être le cas
est ce que le fait qu'il entre en
vigueur tout de suite n'est pas en
contradiction avec une certaine façon de
le voir du conseil d'état et puis en
plus c'est assez étonnant que j'ai cru
entendre que s'agissant du cumul des
mandats parlementaires et locaux
l'application se ferait en 2017
enfin j'ai cru entendre ça et ici on
rentrerait et entrera immédiatement en
application pour un maire d'une commune
de 1000 habitants
je sais pas qui peut le plus peut le
moins mais c'est qui peut le moins peut
pas le plus c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'assez d'assez étonnant donc c'est pour
ça qu'on l'avait déjà déposé ces
amendements en première lecture on le
dépose ses les âmes les mêmes
amendements en seconde lecture
je crois qu'il faudrait supprimer cet
article à qui a été introduit par notre
commission des lois en premier si si en
première lecture est très très
franchement ça fait partie de ces
bizarreries comme la façon de désigner
les délégués des communes ou
intercommunaux des communes de moins de
1000 habitants dont on a parlé on a
parlé tout à l'heure
franchement il y as qu'il ya urgence à
légiférer dans ce domaine là donc tout
simplement
il nous semble que le bon sens veut
qu'on supprime cet article 1a
merci monsieur collombat avis de la
commission monsieur rapporteur je prie
pour la gauche a rendu un avis
défavorable à l'amendement de notre
collègue collombat parce qu'il me paraît
mettre derrière c'est à mon nom derrière
le texte qu'il veut demander
j'allais dire eu quelque chose
d'extraordinairement ample
d'extraordinairement difficile on me dit
que ça n'est qu'un amendement de
coordination ça n'est qu'une disposition
de coordination qu'on doit faire figurer
dans cette semaine dans mes arge ma
culture est infime par rapport à la
vôtre
mon audition est relative aussi mais
j'ai tout de même compris cela ça n'est
qu'un texte coordination donc ça n'ouvre
pas le débat aussi vaste que ce que nous
dit monsieur collomb bas parce qu on est
bien d'accord ce débat vaste c'est pas
l'occasion de ce texte qu'on l'aura s'il
y avait du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
oui d'abord là hein on anticipe sur un
certain nombre de débats que nous aurons
sur les questions liées au cumul
et puis en supprimant monsieur colombes
à l'article 1er du projet de loi
organique
cet amendement conduirait à la censure
des articles du projet de loi ordinaire
qui fixe le seuil du scrutin de listes à
1000 habitants si je me trompe pas oui
donc pour que ces deux raisons j'en
conclu au rejet de votre amendement
merci monsieur richard malgré l'heure
tardive qu'on consacre une minute o neal
est admis à cette affaire que s'est il
passé au moment de la précédente
limitation du cumul des mandats
en 2000 le gouvernent le gouvernement la
majorité de l'époque ont dit ne compte
pas dans les mandats soumis à la
réglementation du cumulent le mandat de
conseiller municipal
c'est qu'on est toujours sur les mandats
d'une commune de moins de 3500 ksa
c'était la loi organique
quels conseils au ciel déclare conforme
tout baigne mais il ya un sujet que le
conseil considérait relève pourquoi
est-ce qu'on très différemment des
conseillers municipaux de communes de
tailles différentes
problème de principe d'égalité et le
conseil répond on peut le faire parce
que on est sur des catégories de
communes qui ont des régimes électoraux
différents donc j'ai un critère objectif
et j'accepte là-dessus la même majorité
le même gouvernement dit finalement à la
réflexion on change le seuil
d'application de proportionnelle à 2005
à ce moment là le conseil constitue un
10 vous m'avez un peu grugé puisque vous
aviez une coïncidence entre un régime
électoral et un seuil de cumul donc là
ça répondait un critère objectif vous
avez rompu après coup cette identité et
donc je vous rattrape au virage et la
loi ordinaire c'est exactement ce qu'il
vient de dire le ministre
à ceux là étaient déclarées
inconstitutionnelles c'est pour ça qu'on
est toujours à 3005 et donc je rejoins
par contre paire yves collombat sur un
point qui est la date d'application
parce que si
la loi dont on parle l'article
organismes dont on parle s'applique
immédiatement ça veut dire que des
collègues qui ont un mandat municipal
dans une commune entre 3500 et wild on
va devoir y renoncer
instantanément alors que le critère qu'à
poser le conseil constitutionnel c'est
si vous avez un régime électoral avec un
seuil
c'est ce même seuil qui doit s'appliquer
pour le le que la limitation du cumul
donc il me semble je ne suis pas vérifié
assez attentivement si le texte était
bien ça mais que cette disposition
organique ne doit entrer en vigueur que
au moment des prochaines municipales
quand s'appliquera le nouveau seuil
d'application de la loi de
proportionnelle avec prime majoritaire
mais la raison pour laquelle on est dans
cette nécessité c'est une c'est quand
même l'application du principe d'égalité
dire que si vous mais si vous faites une
distinction entre les élus municipaux de
communes de diverses tailles
il faut qu' il faut que cette
distinction soit fondée sur un critère
objectif qui à la différence de mode de
scrutin
merci monsieur richert monsieur collants
bas je trouve je trouve cet état de fait
encore plus stupide que je croyais pas
ce que dans qui m'ont et qui montre bien
que notre système
pardon non m'entendais enfin franchement
ça vous choque pas en vous que on puisse
continuer à accumuler tout un tas de
choses si on est on est maire d'une
commune de 100000 habitants aux
présidents d'intercommunalités qu'il ya
cinq cent mille habitants enfin et c'est
président de tout un tas de trucs
et puis qu'on compare on compare avec ce
qui se passe pour un élu d'une commune
de 2
2002 habitants enfin franchement bon
alors que ton contre est donc d'accord
ça mérite peut-être que on voit on voit
là et en particulier parce qu'on le sait
très bien plus que les statuts
juridiques
ce qui importe c'est la fonction c'est
l'importance de là c'est l'importance du
temps que prend chaque mandat c'est le
volume financier gérait enfin etc et
j'en passe j'en passe et des meilleurs
donc arriver à introduire ce type de
modification bon n'en mourra pas mais au
détour comme ça d'une de cette de cette
loi moi ça me paraît vraiment
complètement complètement excessif et
franchement je ne sais pas qui va
comprendre ce genre de choses merci je
vais donc mettre aux voix cet amendement
qui a reçu d'avis défavorables monsieur
lézard
oui simplement sur président un mot pour
rire c'est pas semblant de la
coordination monsieur le rapporteur
parce que s'il y avait une entrée en
vigueur immédiate comme l'a rappelé très
justement alain richer se serait
constitutionnellement extrêmement
contestable puisque ça reviendrait à
changer les règles du jeu électoral
pendant le mandat des actuels
parlementaire merci monsieur le ministre
c'est le monsieur le président il ya
deux débats le premier porte
implicitement nous l'avons déjà évoqué
il y aura un texte de loi n'a pas été
encore d'ailleurs adopté par le conseil
des ministres qui concernera le cumul ou
non cumul des mandats
peut être à d'autres sujets en tout cas
qui permettra dans les débats dans la
bonne humeur de traiter un certain
nombre de questions
pour ce qui concerne le texte et faisant
mienne
évidemment les arguments et du
rapporteur et du sénateur alain richard
il y a un instant je rappelle qu'à
l'article 3 de cette loi organique
il est dit que les articles 1er à et
premier s'applique à compter du prochain
renouvellement des conseils municipaux
suivant
la promulgation de la présente loi
organique on n'échappe pas aux
difficultés que vous évoquez merci je
mets donc aux voix cet amendement qui a
reçu l'avis défavorable de la commission
et du gouvernement quels sont ceux qui
sont pour sur l'adoption avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté trois amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 1 qui le défend à banias
plus d'objets donc les trois amendements
d'autres aussi les trois amendements
tombe pareil des trois amendements
qu'ils soient identiques tombe
voilà donc je fais je vais mettre aux
voix l'article 1er à quels sont ceux qui
sont pour l'adoption avis contraire il
est adopté article 1er les trois
amendements temps bree et nous en
arrivons donc à l'amendement numéro 20
de la commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur d'accord à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
favorable je le mets au bout je le mets
se voit quels sont ceux qui chantent ou
la demande l'adoption d'amendements 20
avis contraire il est adopté un
amendement 5 rectifié madame l'ip est
oui merci monsieur le président c'est un
amendement un petit peu compliqué à
rédiger je remercie toutes les personnes
qui m'ont aidé commission des lois
attaché parlementaire de monsieur le
ministre et les personnes à la tribune
désolé j'ai plus le nom en tête je
commence à fatiguer donc c'est le
problème des du vote aux élections
communales des sans domicile fixe
européen
là ils ont le droit aujourd'hui de voter
aux élections européennes mais la loi
telle qu'elle était la loi organique
telle qu'elle était or écrite les
empêchait de voter aux municipales parce
que les critères d'élection de domicile
et est exclu par cette loi organique
parce que la loi avait été modifiée
postérieurement à la loi organique
j'ai pas si vous me suivez à 1h30 du
matin donc c'est pas grave l'important
c'est que aujourd'hui la france soit en
accord avec les traités européens et
donc par cet amendement
cet amendement vise à permettre aux sans
domicile fixe européens de pouvoir voter
aux prochaines élections municipales
merci madame avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur comme à son
habitude sur le président et on en a eu
plusieurs illustrations manami pièce a
plongé la commission dans un état de
réflexions extraordinairement profond et
après un échange de vues et sortant de
cet état de réflexion la commission at
il s'agit vraiment là d'un problème
qu'on ne peut pas traiter au fond sans
avoir eu la vidéo
si monsieur deux rapporteurs monsieur le
ministre la vie du gouvernement non
c'est vrai c'est un sujet difficile
puisque l'amendement de madame lipietz a
pour objet de permettre aux
ressortissants communautaires inscrit
dans un seces de voter aux élections
municipales
il s'inspire aussi d'un certain nombre
d'évolutions il actualise le compteur
figurant à l'article du code électoral
qui a figé le droit en vigueur pour les
ressortissants communautaires à mai 1998
et n'a pas permis que soit applicable
une nouvelle disposition permettant aux
personnes sans domicile fixe domicilié
dans un ccs de s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales de la commune dans laquelle
est établie
le ccs donc on voit bien les populations
qui sont visés expressément moi je
considère que même si la loi organique
évidemment doit intégrer ce type de
proposition vu les difficultés que nous
pouvons avoir y compris avec un certain
nombre de ces populations
cet amendement peut difficilement être
accepté à ce moment là merci je vais
donc le maître on voit quels sont ceux
qui sont pour son adoption
un lit contraire il n'est pas adopté je
mets donc on voit l'article 1er quels
sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption avis
contraire il est adopté même vote pour
l'article de même votre article 2 bis
avec un amendement qui tombe et je mets
donc convoi l'article 2 bis a même vote
même vote 2 bis b idem puisqu'il tombe
l'amendement 2 bis même vote même vote
de terre pareil article 3 1 leur
amendement 13 rectifié monsieur collomb
bas monsieur mézard
monsieur colombes à la commission des
lois déjà préciser un certain nombre de
choses enfin finalement appliqué le ces
nouvelles dispositions à partir de 1er
avril 2017 ne paraît très en phase avec
l'actualité et cette idée que tout ce
qu'ils les nouvelles règles concernant
le cumul des mandats elle s'appliquerait
à partir de cette de cette date
c'est une belle date si monsieur
collombat avait de la commission
monsieur l'europe
même avis du gouvernement je le mets au
voit quels sont ceux qui sont pour
changer d'option avis contraire il n'est
pas adoptée et je mets aux voix
l'article 3 quels sont ceux qui
souhaitent adopter l'article 3 avis
contraire il est adopté je vais donc
mettre aux voix l'ensemble du projet de
l'organique n'y a pas d'explications de
vote
je mets donc on voit l'ensemble du
projet de loi organique dont la
commission ainsi rédigé l'intitulé
projet de loi organique relatif à
l'élection des conseillers municipaux
des conseillers communautaires et des
conseillers départementaux en
application de l'article 59 du règlement
le scrutin public est de droit il va
être procédé dans les conditions fixées
par l'article 56 du règlement ceux qui
souhaitent voter pour donc remettront un
bulletin blanc contre un bulletin bleu
et cèpes ceux qui s'abstiennent un
bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos et j'invite les
secrétaires a procédé au dépouillement
du scrutin
or